right let's just get right into it i was
asked by jenny if i was team conrad or
team jeremiah gavin don't be mad i said
conrad no
that's the right answer no
wrong answer i'm done
i'm causing the drama right off the bat
um but i seriously want to know what
team are you guys
i gotta be team jeremiah i gotta be too
conrad absolutely that's the one
sean now
if you're picking sides morgan i'm team
jeremiah
[Applause]
thank you
wow that was well done
so amazing you know this show really
focuses on tradition so i'm so curious
what are some of your favorite summer
traditions
you know to be honest with you one of
mine would have to be with my family
thank
hit a home run or you know the yankees
beat the red sox or whatever it is
that's something i mean
oh my dad and i
oh
[Music]
sean's not liking this
ah
i don't think
not just me all right i don't want to
interrupt this
choice
guys help chemistry i felt it uh i don't
want to make you feel uncomfortable
christopher but do you get the whole you
look like young leonardo dicaprio
i've heard it once or twice
but um i
don't see it and i appreciate it
do you do the rest of your cast see it
yeah you know i think that was one of
the first things they said when i met
him honestly i was like dude
that's sweet bro
i don't know he's better looking though
[Laughter]
me too
i like it
um you know it's so exciting that this
series has already been picked up for
season two
when the show hasn't even come out yet
that just shows how excited fans are and
also how great this show is does it feel
like summer camp kind of getting back
together again and getting to shoot this
whole show
very much
yeah yeah it uh
and a simple phrase it feels like
bringing the band back together pretty
much uh you know for a round two it's
it's
oh yeah i sing gavin plays the bass and
chris uh
[Music]
would buy that ticket to watch you in
concert i wouldn't
we would only sell one we couldn't
not one ticket
i'm your biggest fan guys
you